DNCHT OH, MY GOD.
>> EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT.
>> NO.
>> JUST LISTEN.
>> WE HAVE -- WE HAVE HEARD IT.
>> HOW MUCH GAS DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN GET FOR $20.
>> FORGET GAS PRICES, ALL.
>> THAT I CAN'T FORGET GAS
PRICES.
>> IF YOU'RE EMPTY, IF YOU'RE ON
EMPTY, IF YOU'RE HALF, YOU GET
$21, THAT WILL JUST GIVE YOU
MORE CUSHION TO PLAY AROUND.
THIS IS ALL I'M SAYING.
>> PLAY AROUND WHETHER?
>> RATHER GOING ALL THE WAY TO
THE BOTTOM, AND 50, 60, JOED
JUST AID 20.
>> HOW MANY YEARS DO WE HAVE
THIS THING?
>> THREE YEARS?
>> I HAVE ONE QUESTION.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> IF I NEED GO 30 MILES --
>> BRO, DON'T --
>> JUST ANSWER THE QUESTION.
IT'S A SIMPLE -- I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION.
I HAVE TO GO 30 MILES.
AND MY CARGOES FIVE MILES PER
GALLON AND I HAVE THREE
GALLONS --
>> FORGET THE GALLONS.
>> IT A IT DON'T MATTER HOW MUCH
I PUT IN, I CAN'T GO FEARTH -- I
HAVE TO GET 30 MILES.
>> I'M TALKING -- IF I'M AT
HALF.
I DON'T WANT TO KEEP DRIVING.
SHUT THAT UP.
>> DOES IT MATTER?
>> IF I'M AT HALF AND I KEEP
DRIVING, I WILL GO DOWN.
BUT IF I'M GETTING 20 --
>> WHERE YOU DRIVE MATTERS.
IF YOU DRIVE AROUND THE CORNER?
>> I'M GOING FROM YOUR HOUSE TO
THE STUDIO, AND IF I'M HALF --
>> HIS HOUSE?
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THERE.
>> I'M JUST SAYING, YOU'RE HALF
AND I DRIVE THERE YOUR HALF, IT
WILL BRING IT DOWN TO THE
NEGATIVE.
IF I ADD $20, I HAVE CUSHION,
CA